okay so idris elba recently got onto
instagram and he said that he wants
everyone
on the platform to be verified he's 60
though yeah he's 60.
okay he wants everyone to be verified
because he thinks it's weird that you
can go on social media
talk a bunch of [ __ ] or like talk to
people and they don't know who you are
and so he oh i see he says it's similar
so there's no like troll accounts no
troll accounts and i also think it's
just like so you know who you're talking
to like this is an actual person it's
not like you're lying
from a burner account the process of
varication requires them to prove their
identity so everyone knows who is
speaking
social media companies should make this
mandatory i get what you're saying
currently social media is boarding and
playing not having to show id
that would never happen well if cowards
are being supported by a vial of privacy
and
secrecy then social media is not a safe
place
so he just wants it to be more like it'd
make it a nicer place maybe or something
kind of like any kind of regular rachel
that's
not your username so he wants people to
go by like official name
yeah or you could just leave all has uh
the delta the delta
what's happening uh smoking too much
that well also
there you go kids yeah yeah i don't know
i get what idris is saying
are you always saying well he's also
from the uk you don't have freedom of
speech over there right
well they do but in the uk yeah they
have freedom of speech do they the uk
i heard that there's like a specific
like like if you say certain
you can't say certain things like there
was that uh tom daley situation where
someone said that uh
his dad would be disappointed he didn't
like win gold or some [ __ ] and he was
arrested
it was like a random speech you have
free speech in in the uk yeah
canada has um like a hate speech law
there we go that's what i'm thinking
like don't happen that's what jordan
peterson made
got famous for for fighting against and
and they passed it
uh in some ways it's compelled speech um
and i'm not sure i think that's been
challenged
is on the right path though he's saying
like these trolls hide behind these
weird
pseudo names and can just spew out vile
[ __ ]
but if it was under their real legal
name you could find out who they
are then i doubt they're going to be
hide behind this like fake avatar
account yeah i'm down with that
i'm down with it because i think tinder
has something like that where you have
your account verified if you put in your
id
to show like oh this is actually who
they say they are and then they're
attempting that just you're verified
yeah but then again is that a violation
of your privacy just to speak your mind
and and to have your own account that's
the other question yeah but is it but
is it okay to hide behind whatever
booger one two three underscore and just
say racial
no because would you say that same race
as [ __ ] if it was your actual account
absolutely not but that's only one case
the
the real debate is should you know
should you be forced to
disclose your identity when you just
want to interact on social media
and and maybe you just want to remain
anonymous which is your right as a human
being too yeah but that's the exception
isn't it i think
i think so much i disagree i think what
he's saying is like
these people spewing this [ __ ] wouldn't
do it if it was if they have to
i understand consequences i understand
what if i said to you you're not allowed
to be anonymous
you'd be like wait a minute you know i
wouldn't i'd be like yeah cool because
i'm not anonymous
and i would never get behind something
and say some [ __ ] i went so you want to
give
a central power the ability to say you
have to say who you are
yeah i have a problem with it i don't
have a problem i think it's fine to be
another i think it would be clean i'd
clean i think it would clean up the hate
on social media
um okay so then how do you feel about
hate speech would you outlaw it yes
you shouldn't be on the platform outlaw
hate speech yes
shouldn't be on the platforms okay but
what about if you so so you you would
not allow
people to to say something racist
in general not on not if i own twitter
facebook or youtube no okay they're
they're
they are allowed you are allowed now on
twitter and facebook as long as it's not
directed
to at someone specifically right because
that falls under your first amendment
right i happen to believe in the first
amendment which is you're allowed to say
anything you want um the the one thing
there are there are exceptions like
screaming fire in a thing or advocating
violence directly towards somebody
saying go kill that guy that would be
that would be you'd be in trouble for
that sure but overall you know
protecting free speech is very important
in general right
and i think to a certain extent and i
well to every extent to me but but i
mean
yes i don't think so there are i think
when kids are committed suicide getting
bullied on social media there has to be
some recourse or
action we can't say well it's freedom of
speech it's okay that this well there
are harassment laws
there are harassment laws right so there
are but you have to be very careful
about
you know i think when you say well
you're not allowed to be anonymous
so i can't write a book that's anonymous
i can't say something that's anonymous
because sometimes you want to just
express yourself
under a pseudonym sometimes you have a
pen name which which authors have done
so
it's a slippery slope is what i'm trying
to say and and it's a debate that i
think has been had
and thought about pretty s pretty pretty
thoroughly
you say i don't think so on social media
no not social media
on social media
category from having a uh well that was
for
so that's the other thing they said
you're spreading misinformation well
there you go so so
then they kind of said basically we
don't want him to be able to contact
this phone
well but i understand so so facebook
let's just take facebook let's take
twitter
let's take um
uh instagram music instagram no let's
take youtube let's take youtube
let's take facebook let's say um twitter
um
you if if you have a group of people
spreading like they've they've got a
sophisticated
um information network and they start
saying
something like this particular group of
people let's say koreans
or chinese people in this particular
neighborhood are responsible for
x y and z and it's a lie and we've seen
this in other countries and then you get
a mob of people
that with their pitchforks come into
that neighborhood and start causing
rican damage sure or let's just talk
about what's going on now
say what you will about vaccines but
vaccines
do have an effect they have had a
positive effect
on i'm going to get [ __ ] for this but on
on the fact that covet is no longer as
much a threat
and old people take it they can move
about and they won't die
because they're immune to covet that if
you look at the
two billion plus people who've had it
and you look at the actual
data the real data from all over the
world that bears
that bears out that is a fact when you
have people who are
actively spreading misinformation about
a vaccine like for example it makes
women infertile
which is not true there's just no
science to that but there are strong
networks that are saying that and people
are buying into it so people aren't
getting the vaccine as a
platform you kind of have a duty to
tackle that you have a duty to kind of
go
i might get sued this is misinformation
and it's actually causing the economy to
stay closed
this is not freedom of speech back to
your point that would be
this is my this is the biggest challenge
we face
misinformation and deliberate
misinformation lying
uh on a platform when you own it
privately you might be responsible for
that so you kind of have to limit
free speech in that sense that's what
i'm saying but but then you open up the
floodgates because then
we're it's a big [ __ ] problem i don't
have the answer i
i am a big advocate of free speech in
the first amendment 100
and the way to deal with free speech is
more free speech but we are
we are dealing with a precedent we've
never had to deal with it before right
that's what i'm saying
yeah i don't think it's been looked at
or studied that much well it's new
i mean i'm saying you're into your point
that's your point yeah that's my
original point to your point
so what do you do because you get so
much [ __ ] when you censor people i don't
think you allow hate speech or
misinformation
that's their responsibility how do you
define hate speech
here's the problem now because
somebody's defining that
so the problem with define hate speech
is if i say a man is a man and a woman
is a woman
or if i say biological women biological
men
shouldn't be in women's sports let me
tell you something
that's considered hate speech on a lot
of platforms why
because a very active minority tiny
group of people that are very active and
loud
are bullying and making it very
dangerous for you to say otherwise
because you will lose your job
now we've got a problem you understand
slippery slope it is that's that's and
and
we know that historically it's a
slippery slope because somebody has to
delineate
and designate and define what what hate
speech is
and that's why every time it hits the
supreme court it's shot down because
because you're like who's the one who's
who the [ __ ] is saying this is hate
speech because you can start saying
anything
and this this agenda with this trans
trans agenda thing
there are people in that group who are
who are just not reasonable about
certain things
do you think biological men should be
allowed to compete in women's fighting
for example
i i i mean you know or or do you think
i'm do you think of a man who had
no estrogen replacement let's just take
an extreme example
and they have long hair or whatever and
they say i want to i want to sprint
in the women's division of the olympics
i think i think they need to
they need to open up more divisions for
more transgender there you go
that's fine now hold on they they should
be allowed to completely
get sanctioned for saying that sometimes
in certain platforms you really could
you'd be in some trouble for saying that
you'd get blow back
and you and if you worked for certain
organizations they would tell you you
have to
you have to apologize for what you just
said for sure right
and that's that's where i that's why
protecting freedom of speech is so
[ __ ] important
it's just a slippery slope man it's
[ __ ] see we get into this and all of
a sudden you're like you realize how
thick it is he's just like
i don't envy i don't envy youtube and
twitter
i don't envy that having to deal with
that [ __ ] that